our next speaker is a proud graduate of
Yale College who received his MD from
Cornell and his PhD from Rockefeller
University in New York followed by a
residency in pathology at Brigham and
Women's Hospital in Boston he is now
associate professor in the department's
of Laboratory Medicine and pathology his
research focuses on telomeres yes I can
pronounce that word the structures at
the ends of our chromosomes that
maintain the integrity of our genetic
information using mouse models his
laboratory was the first to show that
telomere binding proteins are required
to prevent the onset of features of
premature aging in stem cells
please welcome dr. sandy Chang the topic
the longest short of it telomeres in
aging and cancer
well thank you very much for that
introduction and thank you to the Yale
Pepper Center for this invitation to
speak to this illustrative form okay so
I'm gonna switch gears a little bit for
Mary's talk I'm gonna tell you about
cellular aging so the first aspect of
celery and I want to tell you about it's
an experiment done in the 5th and the
60s by a Leonard hayflick and it was a
very simple II conception simple
experiment but with a profound
implication so Leonard hayflick took
normal human skin cells from young
patients and just passes them in culture
so what he found was that these cells
instead of growing indefinitely like you
found in normal cancer cells these cells
actually stopped dividing at a very
defined stage around 60 or 70 population
doublings this was very strange because
it's at the time when cancer cells were
used as a model cancer cells are
immortal they divided indefinitely but
there's something intrinsic about normal
human fibroblasts that stop your cell
division and in fact they became
senescence they adopt a very strange
phenotype quite unlike their youthful
counterparts the cells are flat they
develop binding a pile of nuclei and
they stop dividing but they are still
metabolically active
so these senescence cells are at the
time not understood as to why they form
so when now we know that it is because
telomeres the structures the caps the
ends of all eukaryotic chromosomes and
they're the ones the telomere structures
are the ones that dictate the the
ability of cells to to divide for
example telomere length is very
predictive of the replicative history of
a cell and telomeres are actually
repetitive DNA sequences the caps the
ends of our chromosomes and because
telomeres are intrinsic to ourselves
they offer their divisions offer a
replicative history as to how many
cycles a cell can divide and you can
think of telomeres as the caps that the
plant little plastic caps at the ends of
our shoelaces so in a functional
shoelace with the proper capping
function you can thread the shoelaces
into holes are these shoelaces are
functional that these are like the
telomeres and youthful self
if you lose the plastic caps and
divisive laces your shoelaces become
frayed no longer functional and these
are like the telomeres of senescence
cells they're no longer functional no
long is their the capping function and
they're called dysfunctional so this
illustrates why telomeres become
dysfunctional and the reason why is
because telomeres are part of the linear
chromosomes and these cannot be
replicated by the DNA polymers for
machinery so this is what's called an
end replication problem and because of
the failure for DNA polymerase to fully
replicate linear chromosomes telomere
length shirin and you can actually run
these out on a gel you can see that
telomeres and mortal cells actually
decline and they become very short
instant as in cells if you look at
telomere length in human white blood
cells you can see that telomeres
actually whittle down by about seventy
base pairs per year of life and you know
in a long course organism like humans
you can imagine that the amount of
telomeres that we lose could be quite
substantial something like 5,000 to
8,000 base pairs in our lifespan so what
is what is the mechtogan telomere
shortening in important cells such as
our stem cells so this is the enzyme
telomerase enzyme I'm sure many of you
have heard of the enzyme Thomas has been
usurped this is a reverse transcriptase
you serve other chaotic organisms to add
telomeres de novo to the ends of your
character chromosomes there in Columbus
are ttaggg repetitive sequences to a
chromosome ends thereby circumventing
the end replication problem and we we
now know that telomerase is expressed
only in certain restricted cell types
for example are stem cells and room
cells have telomerase activity but are
somatic cells do not and that's why the
somatic cells telomeres shorten and on
the gold replicative senescence
unfortunately the level of trauma is an
estimate on us in our germ cells and our
stem cells does not appear to be enough
so even though those cells have
telomerase the telomeres still continue
to short
in contrast cancer cells have robust
levels of telomerase they divide
indefinitely and area mortal so I should
mention that the discovery of telomeres
and telomerase was awarded the Nobel
Prize in 2009 and this work was
pioneered by dr. Liz Blackburn with
colleague Jack show starts and Carol
Greider and the reason why I put this
slide here is because telomeres we
actually discovered at Yale when dr.
Blackburn was a postdoc in Joe galls lab
at the Yale Medical School that's where
they discovered this unique structure at
the ends of the chromosomes of
tetrahymena so this is this slide
illustrates our telomere hypothesis of a
gene enhancer and this hypothesis has
received a lot of experimental
confirmation from work done in my own
lab and as well as those from others so
what we postulate is that telomeres
shorten because of insufficient live or
telomerase and the dysfunctional
telomeres in suit and these are actually
recognized as damaged DNA so
dysfunctional telomeres activate a very
potent DNA damage response that's p53
dependent so p53 is the guardian of the
genome it's a DNA it's activated by DNA
damage and it's a checkpoint so
activation of p53 actually elicits the
onset of cellular senescence and in some
cells apoptosis as well so cells
actually die when they encounter
dysfunctional telomeres in the presence
of intact p53 so this is actually very
potent anti-cancer mechanism we've
evolved this method to prevent cells
with dysfunctional telomeres from
hanging around so we try to get rid of
them by either stopping their cell
division or by killing them
unfortunately an unintended consequence
of this anti-tumor mechanism is that
stem cell populations or in highly
proliferative organs diminish their
function and giving rise to premature
aging phenotypes on the other hand
dysfunctional telomeres in the setting
of the p53 mutation which is commonly
encountered in many human cancers
actually is a pro cancer mechanism
dysfunctional telomeres in the setting
of people are 3 deficiency actually
drives tumor Genesis and I want to
a little bit about this today so we know
that cancer incidence increases age and
in fact aging is actually the most
important cause of human cancer so if
you look at telomere length in human
prion neoplastic lesions for example at
the doctor car some insight to you in
breast cancer telomeres actually very
short in pre neoplastic lesions and this
is illustrated by this diagram here this
is a dr. carcinoma in situ you of the
breast
you can see that nuclei are illustrated
in in blue and telomeres are these
little pink dots so in basal epithelial
cells ridges are support cells of the
breast dock you can see plenty of
telomeres at these in these cells
in contrast the neoplastic luminal
epithelial cells have very short
telomeres because of their increased
replicated histories and these are the
cells that will give rise to breast
cancer so this slide shows that pre
neoplastic lesions have already very
short telomeres and very short telomeres
actually in general chromosomal
instability so chromosome end-to-end
fusions are a common feature of cells
very very short telomeres you can see it
here chromosomes are painted blue with
stained copy telomeres like these little
red dots at the ends of chromosomes and
these yellow arrows points to
chromosomes that have fused end to end
you can see that the side of the fusion
there are no telomere signals telomeres
are so sure that they've already joined
together causing massive genome
instability without you engineer this
model in the laboratory mice and in
which we delete telomerase and the
checkpoint protein p53 together in mouse
models so what happens that these mice
get cancer readily breast cancer skin
cancer and invasive colon carcinomas
interestingly if you inherit short
telomeres sarcastically you are also
prone to develop cancer so the cancer
incidence of patients with the shortest
telomeres is something like threefold
higher than patients with the longest
telomeres and also cancer mortality also
increases so the acquisition of short
telomeres
it's not a good thing in terms of cancer
biology so this can be explaining this
diagram here we think that with
increasing epithelial cell renewal with
advancing age telomeres shorten in the
absence of telomerase these telomeres
become recombinase genic they become
sticky they undergo end to end
chromosome fusion generating what's
called by centric chromosomes
chromosomes are two centromeres and
these structures are inherently unstable
they get pulled to opposite poles of the
spindle preserving cell division
generated chromosome breaks and
amplifications deletions and for example
amplifications of oncogenes or deletions
of tumor suppressors could generate a
genetic Miglia that's permissive for
cancer growth so this is what happens
across our insight to you the telomeres
are very short but there's genetic
rearrangement that's already permissive
for cancer development well human
cancers do in this stage is that they
can reactivate the enzyme polymers so
they normally do not express harm it's
at this point but when they reactivate
it they can now become invasive cancers
that they metastasize the distance to
kill their host
in fact 90% of all human cancers
reactivate telomerase the other 10%
utilizes a alternative lengthening of
telomeres of recombination based
mechanism to maintain their telomere
length in any anyway cancers do it they
have to maintain telomere length to
become invasive so what I've Illustrated
is that we have a telomere reserve
that's usually enough for to maintain
health up to maybe around 70 or so years
of age so the telomere theory of aging
also will postulate that in case people
patients individuals and Herot mutations
in telomere length maintenance program
for example in telomerase will have
inherently shorter telomeres and these
shorter telomeres should trigger the
onset of disease at an earlier age and
now we have very reliable ways to
measure telomere length in human
populations so these are five
individuals that I've illustrate here
and these are telomere lengths and they
look like a little Gaussian distribution
and this red line shows the average
telomere length in humans so you can see
that in this particular
patient number two the telomeres are
very short excuse to the left if you
analyze patient number two in more
detail they actually have a lot of
telomeres that are quite critically sure
many of them under a KB is also of
length and in fact patient number two
develop a telomere disease we call them
Tila mapa 'they now call this this
keratosis congenital this characters can
generates a human disease is a telomere
disease patients have characteristic
skin phenotypes they have extremely
short telomeres telomeres less than the
first percentile and they also developed
very early bone marrow failure sometimes
as early as thirty years of age in some
cases as 12 of 13 year olds bone marrow
failure is characteristic of this
disease as well as a very high increase
in cancer incidence for example the
develop of AML and pulmonary fibrosis is
another feature that we see in these
patients so short telomeres in this
setting develop these whole host of
human syndromes that are not that can be
actually be modeled in the laboratory
mice so in this diagram I've shown you
that if you delete a telomere binding
protein called protection of Atilla
marijuana part one the telomeres become
critically short and he-man aquatic stem
cells as illustrated by these boxes here
and actually become lost over time so
here's part one knockout mice a two
month of age four month of ages six
month of age you can see that the
hematopoietic cells gradually diminish
and around six months series the stem
cells almost completely gone and this is
coupled with almost Coto bone marrow
failure that we see a good phenol copy
of the disease that we see in humans and
in fact we now know that there are many
pathways that need to be maintained in
order to prevent the onset of this
characteristic ageneral and these are
all pathways involved in telomere length
maintenance I've told you about
telomerase both the traumas aren't a
component and the protein component
could be mutated to cause discounters
agenda as well as components that's
involved in the maturation of this
enzyme
deletion of part one and as I just show
you
causes the disease and mouse and
mutations in this killing a binding
protein 10 - causes this keratosis
congenital in humans at a very young age
12 year olds get bone marrow failure we
recently demonstrated that if you
perturb telomere length replication
factors for example a protein called CTC
one critically important in telomere
replication these mites also get bone
marrow failure there early and eliciting
a phenotype reminiscent of this
characters was congenital so I've told
you that short telomeres are could be
pretty bad in terms of symptoms that
occur cause so is there any way that we
could ameliorate these short kilometres
and maybe perhaps increase telomere
length so one obvious way is to express
telomerase this is could be rarely done
in cells if you overexpress telomerase
telomere length increase and you bypass
the hayflick limit so here ourselves
without telomerase this the Nets have
population doubling of 60s I'll show you
earlier but in the setting of kilometers
over expression these cells are not
immortal and what's amazing is that even
though these cells are immortal and
replicating they do not have any genomic
instability suggesting that expression
autonomous may be a way in the future to
slow down the rate of telomere
shortening we already could do this in
cells and recent publication from the
depend on lab have shown that if you
overexpress telomerase in the laboratory
Mouse it can actually rescue many of the
stem cell functions and increased
lifespan in this mouse model so the hope
is that in the future we could prevent
the onset of or the development of
dysfunction with telomeres and then if
you know miscibility induced by the
dysfunction Amir's through selective
activation or transient activation of
kilometers and maybe we can even use
this to decrease our resistance to
stress and do cellular senescence well
these are the benefits of transient
telomeres therapy we also
be cognizant of the fact that increased
Harmons expression may not be always be
a good thing I always have to worry
about that if you increase the doubling
rate of any cell you increase the rate
of DNA mutations that most of the
mutation happen during DNA replication
and if you increase proliferation of pre
malignant cells for example pre
malignant cancer initiating cells for
example perhaps the increase in cancer
incidence will be inevitable so the
challenge in the future is to somehow
add kilometers to the good stem cells
for example and not trigger onset of
cancer
so in summary I've told you that some of
the inherited factors like for example
the acquisition of short telomeres or
the mutations in telomere length
maintenance pathways accelerate telomere
shortening generate dysfunctional
telomeres let's access that DNA damage
promoting agent and depending on the
status of p53 telomere dysfunction can
actually promote the onset of in which
you're aging through stem cell
exhaustion or in the in this setting of
period 3 deficiency generate cancer
through increased genome instability we
can now reliably diagnose your telomeres
so this is maybe one way we could
quickly apply this to the clinic in a
more general setting to look at people
that comes to the hospital to look at
the telomere length so perhaps here with
very short telomeres we could help them
by suggesting for example lifestyle
changes we know that environmental
toxins like reactive oxygen species
carcinogens cigarette smoking also leads
to progressive telomere length
shortening so so changes in lifestyle
may be beneficial so just want to thank
members our lab am I gonna listen more
by name they're illustrated here and I
want to thank my funding sources
particularly the National Institute of
Aging and dr. Hodes
for his support of my research thank you
very much